my my glorious wife and my
and my hilarious son definitely helped
me not feeling
like lonely of course yeah um so that i
mean
i i i only wish that you could find what
i have
when it's hard well you know by the way
i know congrats
on the the you know you got a kid
another kid on the way
well what you have another kid on the
way
i no yeah
dude i talked to jess i i thought you
are you serious yes she told you
yeah she told me you lied bastard
ah but you do you have another one
coming you
yeah little thompson he's the cutest
little you know there's nothing more
infuriating than when
beautiful people have beautiful children
i'm telling you
like we you and i facetime last week and
thompson started talking but and i was
like this is what happens
uh you know you're friends with kids
because i kept just putting thompson on
the facetime with you over and over
i know thank you same mentality level
it's good but i find myself being like
hey man i know i'm biased but this kid's
here but
you know what he is yes he's a good
cute funny kid he makes me laugh all the
time